ما الذي نعرفه عن هذا الاجتماع
وأهميته في هذه المرحلة
حسنًا ، من المهم أن الملك عبد الله
هو أول زعيم عربي يلتقي
بجو بايدن في البيت الأبيض ، لكن
يجب أن نتذكر أنه في الواقع في
فبراير
2017 كان الملك عبد الله أيضًا أول
زعيم عربي  لقاء
الرئيس ترامب آنذاك ،
لمجرد أن هذا النوع من البداية ليس
ضمانًا لعلاقة جيدة ، لكننا نعلم أن
الملك عبد الله يعرف الرئيس
بايدن منذ سنوات عديدة بسبب
منصب الرئيس بايدن
في الكونجرس الأمريكي الآن بقدر ما
كما
هو مدرج في جدول الأعمال ، فإنه بالتأكيد سيعيد
التأكيد على الدور الرئيسي
للأردن في المنطقة مع الأخذ في الاعتبار
أه خلال السنوات الرابحة ، كان الأردن
خاصة الملك عبد الله قد تم
تنحيته جانبًا
عندما كان ترامب منخرطًا في إدارة ثلاثية
مع رئيس الوزراء بنيامين  نتنياهو
في إسرائيل
وولي العهد السعودي عبد محمد بن
سلمان ، كان الأردنيون قلقين للغاية
على سبيل المثال
العام الماضي عندما  تلاعب الإسرائيليون بفكرة
ضم الضفة الغربية ،
وتم إقناعهم أخيرًا بتأجيل ذلك ،
لكن ذلك لا يزال معلقًا فوق رأس الأردن
كما تفعل الطموحات السعودية
للحصول على نوع من الوصاية
على الحرم الشريف ، المكان المقدس
، جبل المعبد كما هو معروف.
اليهود في
القدس وبالطبع في الوقت الحالي
لدى الأردن تلك الوصاية ،
لذا فهم يريدون الحفاظ على
موقعهم المركزي.
أيضا
سوريا والعراق حيث تشارك الولايات المتحدة
في كلا البلدين
متورطين بعمق وبالتالي
أه يريد الأردن التأكد من أن
موقفه واضح جدا في ظل هذه
الإدارة
الجديدة وهي بدأت تؤتي ثمارها بالفعل
الأسبوع الماضي أودعت الولايات المتحدة
600 مليون دولار  في
الخزينة الأردنية
كجزء من حزمة مساعدات إجمالية تبلغ 1.26 مليار دولار
لعام 2021. بيكي